il y a
[Musique]
il y a donc une religion pour changer un
peu des Juifs
qui va voir le curé de sa paroisse et
qui lui dit mon père
j'ai un gros gros soucis j'ai une paire
de femelles perroquet qui passe leur
temps à dire une phrase
abominable et j'ose pas vous la dire mon
père
ose ma fille
et bien elle disent nous sommes deux
procédures alors le prêtre il dit mais
c'est pas possible mais c'est affreux je
te crois je vous comprends mais je crois
que j'ai peut-être une solution
il se trouve que moi aussi j'ai une
paire de perroquet mais ils sont mal et
en plus je leur ai appris à prier et à
lire la Bible donc à leur contact elles
vont finir par adorer Dieu alors la
religieuse le lendemain matin apporte
amen les femelles et on les place
naturellement dans la cage des mâles et
les femelles évidemment engagent la
conversation et elles disent nous sommes
des pro
les amis alors il y a l'un des mâles qui
dit à l'autre nous prions
[Applaudissements]
ça tombe mal parce qu'en ce moment j'ai
des pertes blanches et qui dit bah c'est
pas grave moi j'ai du diabète on va
faire des meringues
[Applaudissements]
eh bien Marie ça va bien sûr
[Rires]
c'est pas possible ça c'est
Emmanuel Macron il est en visite en
Australie
pour un peu détruire
le président d'Australien il le reçoit
monsieur Macron va faire un peu la
visite de Sydney on va se balader en
Australie et là ils sont en voiture et
un mouton qui passe et Emmanuel Macron
ça c'est un mouton chez nous en France
les moutons qu'est-ce qu'ils sont gros
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont balais c'est pas
un mouton ça il marche et tout et d'un
coup il lui dit et ça c'est quoi il dit
ça ça c'est un lapin
les lapins en France ils sont balaise
grand super et là d'un coup il y a un
kangourou qui passe non ça c'était quoi
petit dessin c'est une sauterelle
[Applaudissements]
il s'en va il va jouer aux cartes il est
jamais là elle lui dit écoute j'en ai
ras-le-bol maintenant j'ai envie de
partir en soirée avec toi donc j'ai
trouvé une boîte de nuit qui se trouve à
côté de la maison on va y aller monsieur
les perturbé c'est Dina franchement j'ai
pas envie à mon âge d'aller en boîte et
tout non si si je te laisse pas le choix
on y va prends sa veste son manteau il
s'en va et là il y a une queue de
monstre une heure de queue tu vois je te
l'avais dit ça sert à rien de venir et
tout non sa femme elle reste focus elle
veut absolument rentrer dans cette boîte
de nuit et puis là d'un coup le videur
il appelle monsieur ben tu sais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ne faites pas la
queue venez directement dans la boîte de
nuit bon alors sa femme elle commence à
Richter elle se dit mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe oh il doit comprendre écoute tu
voulais rentrer dans la boîte maintenant
allez on y va ok il y a pas de souci on
rentre dans la boîte là il est accueilli
par le serveur le serveur monsieur mène
tout ça je vous ai réservé le carré
comme d'habitude les bouteilles les
fumigènes monsieur ben tout ça dans la
maison là sa femme commence à se dire oh
dis-moi tu me prends pour pas possible
tu fais quoi le week-end quand j'ai pas
là mais non je te dis qu'il doit
confondre avec quelqu'un écoute
laisse-toi aller ok là gogo dans ses
salariés monsieur ben sous sang comme
d'habitude allez on y va à son nez trop
pour sa femme elle prend son manteau
elle s'en va monsieur ben tout ça il
sait plus où donner de la tête la gogo
la les bouteilles sa femme qui court il
rattrape sa femme ils prennent un taxi
et là sa femme à lui hurle dessus tu me
prends pour une idiote tu me manques
depuis toutes ces années finalement tu
mets en boîte de nuit à ton âge tu as
pas honte et là le taxi il se retourne
et puis vous savez monsieur Ben Soussan
des [ __ ] on en a ramené mais des
comme elle jamais
[Applaudissements]
après je propose qu'on fasse un dernier
tour pour la fin
comment ça marche
alors
[Musique]
justement on va parler vas-y on fait on
fait on fait la blague et après on fait
la prendre allez
alors ces deux gars deux piliers de
barre ils sont comptoir tous les deux là
comme ça un moment donné il y en a un
qui dit j'ai acheté une voiture
électrique
comme ça quand je rentre chez moi je
fais pas de bruit j'ai acheté le portail
électrique toujours pas de bruit j'ai
mis de la moquette dans le garage pas de
bruit j'ai enlevé toutes les portes j'ai
acheté un matelas anti mouvement mais à
chaque fois que je me couche [ __ ] ça
réveille ma faim mais gueule les gars
moi quand je rentre chez moi avec le
pare-buffle le portail
je fais un petit dérapage comme ça sur
les graviers ça fait aboyer le chien je
me défoncer la porte comme ça je me
déshabille je monte comme ça et je me
jette dans le lit et je gueule après une
bonne cuite je me ferais bien sucer et
ben elle se réveille jamais
[Applaudissements]